e eu gostei que assim a gente acabou
indo mais para a cultura de produto e
como instalar cultura de produtos acho
que super vale a gente saber em poucos
em um tuíte o que que é cultura de
produtos para cada um de você porque ela
pergunta legal a gente costuma fazer em
outros lugares também aqui novos
episódios aí vai episódio que a gente
fez isso o que o que tem como é que
definiria a cultura de produtos assim de
maneira assim que você falou assim tô tô
levando da cultura produziu para saber o
que é mais o dinheiro e acho que é o
mesmo caso que ela foi e falou ali né
Por favor claro fica mais fácil é o
mesmo causa de como é que você fala com
as pessoas que não são de produtos um
pouco mais sobre a cultura de produtos
então enfim falei demais quero ver de
vocês o que em um tweet que a cultura de
produto eu vou tentar ser resumida só
mas não seja aí fez o corpo
eu
acho que a cultura de produtos tem muito
a ver com você começar do valor gerado e
das Dores que você quer resolver do Biz
azul do cliente assim então você começar
a tomar a pessoa sair para o micro então
a forma que eu vejo
pessoas produto é por onde você começa o
processo de tomada de decisão assim você
não vai começar a tipo olhando para o
monte de bebê Quest previsão entendi
você vai olhar tipo o cara não vou
entender qual que é só trás do negócio
quais são eu não tô sendo resumidamente
também depois é difícil para caramba
eu falei isso mas eu acho que é isso
assim acho que é muito de começar do
Makro de por micro Então você começa com
uma visão mais holística de todas as
oportunidades e problemas que você tem
que resolver e entra dessa visão que
Connect Dores dos clientes com o valor
para o negócio então você começar a
disso como o start de qualquer processo
de perenização de fez organização enfim
como a gente faz um tweet a gente pega
um pedaço da hatred in
vai pegar um pedaço da TED pra mim
cultura de produto é você
resolver ter a possibilidade de resolver
o mesmo problema de várias formas então
uma vez que você entende com mais
profundidade problema você sabe onde ele
está conectado era Vamos criar em
formatos para resolver aquela mesma dor
eu na minha cabeça sempre brinco com
time tem três formas pessoas processos e
produto Ah pois você vai resolver só com
pessoas ver se vai resolver mudando os
processos você resolver com produtos
vezes os três mas é isso é uma Insight
de cara tem um uniforme de resolver
aquela mesma dor não é o mais certo
experimentação testar uma série de
hipóteses e aí gostou desse corte se
você quiser assistir episódio completo
basta clicar no link aqui na descrição e
se você gostou e quer deixar a gente
sabendo disso deixa o like e assine
nosso canal para gente continuar
trazendo conteúdo gratuito aqui no
YouTube